no no five I give a [ __ ] I look at these
everybody today gonna kill Michael kill
me my guys feet like you sleep hey this
is here and I have my guest here Tracy
Morgan hometown boy I love you Tracy
Mike what's up my fee looking good man
Thank You Man Oh for the gate Tuesday
night woman when the show came on are
you the season yeah tell me about the
rain and how the raining gun a launch
pad for our show is NC double-a baseball
basketball or let's shut down so we
didn't really have a launch pad
and you coming back for season four
awesome thank you Frank I want to give
you two episodes and we already have
those all right I don't but I'm playing
you against character this ain't gonna
be on a funny [ __ ] I need you useful in
a different way and I'm moving I sat
down and I spoke with you you almost
made me choke up I want to show you to
America in a different way in a
different way and the episode is gonna
be with you and prime time okay well we
was in there having that talk au
chocolat prime my wheels are turning
that's episode that some first episode
season four all right but maybe you've
been there before
a kid trying to come out of Brownsville
come you don't filming him browse them
all right man with you man you are his
trainer and the drug dealers in the
neighborhood trying to get at them
so in that episode gonna be me you
Method Man it's gonna be heavy duty all
right cool
cause you know when I was little before
you can't Mike I saw you twice
you richer man on 42nd Street and he was
like notice I made my choice
you gonna be away you just stand there
and the second time not Freeland that's
my grandmother's godson he Thompkins cuz
you know our dad just going all of them
yes from non I teen that's the building
my grandmother liveth
we knew Danny just going on from
Brownsville they have more the talking
and they moved to Tompkins ya know your
father lived in my building
yeah dad who taught you problem
yeah you don't know it that's why I
still feel so connected to you I listen
I listen to you I followed you a little
a little more feeling when he wanna when
he wanted let me go he came back to
target put it on his neck he's a little
kid he run up and we touch it and all my
life I said of mark to do it I could do
it and that's why I'm here today talking
right now man you wanna fight undisputed
I give a [ __ ] I look at these anyways
today I gonna kill them
Mike will kill me Mike and speed like
Bruce Lee speed is power but I'll never
forget class tomorrow said Custer Mike
when you got a mile on a road do not get
excited
exactly alright so much I remember when
your movie first came out and I'll show
you at the premiere in LA and I cried
like a baby in there man when you saw my
cuts I think I love my gray I love Mike
man mike is my OG man and I watched
hotbox true and I gotta come on that
show and get down over your arm
cool promise me man promise me Mike
trust me okay what we're doing what we
don't we'll be doing okay what's the
deal man tell me how this quarantine
what it is really slowing down for you
and I gotta say to get man I'm gonna get
my wife pregnant man come on Mike
that's beautiful I'm old school I don't
pull out kid uh yeah I'm my wife can't
get pregnant but we're practicing a lot
listen if God water is gonna happen kid
I hate but you get a lot of practice
dad we have communicated still I'm
trying to break any mercury record man
man I mean you got 15 16 kids in a 30
years old I love it yo you're Mike you
know this coronaviruses the equal lava
is the equalizer don't matter who you
are we're all in the same situation they
finally got his pimp I'm on lockdown man
they got me in solitary confinement man
the government trying to give me money
to snitch is everyday you try on an
island I said I wanted me maybe some
isolation is good for the mind in the
soul needed a fortress of solitude kid
absolutely after you fight crime he had
to fly somewhere chill so that's a video
we get children right now you're Mike
you're like what was your favorite crime
you might eat went eating what do you
eat the most well last night my wife
made a big pan of lasagna with six
different cheeses oh man
so I'm killing that that's gonna last
about three days
I love leftover lasagna that's what it
is I'll give me a nice plate of lasagna
and I go in my office and I watch
wu-tang clan of Mike's and men I've been
watching before we can have loved some
of it too I watched some of them when
they first started out you know he never
lost vision yo you know I took from it
today I took he set up a man woman is
man woman and child purpose in life is
evolution we come out to cave somebody
got on the wall
the generation Mohandas got to evolve
past us so it's all about evolution I
looked at you how you evolved you
looking at me how about we got to keep
evolving that's the reason why the
dinosaur they're no more
they evolved quick enough you got
evolvement I don't know evolving is good
but some people are involved quick
enough now they don't that's why the
dinosaurs are here so I've been just
watching that coming he had even
watching the tiny King everybody been
watching the tiny thing you know
watching that I watched it and it was
weird and by the third episode I was
like this ain't even about no [ __ ]
Tigers was about the mothership there's
a psychopathic [ __ ] and it about
joining two husbands and kids that they
allegedly killed her husband
yo it was insane it my do open his mouth
he had three teeth
and two of those in his pocket ah man
that was and what about the woman I got
the tiger to rip her arm off and she
went back to work the next week I said
no this is [ __ ] sick this is sick if
my [ __ ] house can help me [ __ ] you
go on outside
that's a little bit listen um can you
imagine how their life is like the date
this all you have to go to oh you're bad
God she didn't even sue she went back to
work for he took that slave mentality yo
that was sore some cold [ __ ] to know
that on some cold [ __ ] yeah yeah I feel
bad for the animals man I feel bad for
the animals because you know they were
mistreated
he was taking the animals out I'm
telling them when they let no more use
for them
yeah I was like on some slave [ __ ]
that's what they did okay you can't pick
this much cotton you got a die
[ __ ] yeah it was a turn your
skin into oil
Hausa and so they did your mic cuts a
son yes please sat down we sat down a
rat
you probably one of the smartest people
ever no matter where you see life man I
bet a [ __ ] you think outside the box
like me yeah I don't know that I find
that but I don't know why I think that
you think I way no way
Watchmen those are very stimulating
conversations you be added and I noticed
you listen a lot too you listen you know
what listen know what let me explain if
you know what I always thought because I
remember being young and some idiot from
the neighborhood would go to prison he
come out you know Sonny thinks he knows
something right and listen right this is
what I understand took us and that guy
is an interesting guy because this is
where I run some that guy going through
my journey I realized that he came out
of driven he was an idiot but he was he
believed he would teach it and once he
began teaching and he thought he would
teach it
he began a large nerve and what he began
to learn he never stopped teaching only
my teachers learn yo you know what's
[ __ ] up when you don't know how to
learn people have to learn how to learn
there's like human beings we forget how
to relax no life is happiness so much
it's what we think of relaxation
somebody relaxation is target practice
well let me tell you some of your people
that's the lactation some people some
people think charity is relaxation
giving is relaxation we have different
perspectives right right mom what I was
so was contemplation and to reflect on
your past and that's better than praying
our past in our life even though they
said never look back
if you don't look back we can't
anticipate our future right suit you
need to be anticipated even though if it
doesn't turn out the way we anticipated
but it has to be anticipated we can't we
can't we can't wing it we can't wing it
in life we have to anticipate and
outcome you know what might whatever I'm
around you
I'll say something to trigger you to
teach me because I learned no I'm
learning I'm learning from hearing you I
can't learn to let that had somebody to
learn fun no but you know what else you
know gonna idiot cannot teach an idiot
well you know what the deal is we
destroyed then we build you can't build
and destroy you got to destroy the
fallacies in order to build the house so
when I'm with when I'm with that
heavyweight championship
undisputed unified do it they do a
parade for me Istanbul all these things
I try to gain knowledge cuz I know you
got it from cus I still look at cutters
they show that he has on on you on
YouTube
cus it's just wisdom I forget the name
of it but it just cuts talking and he
was teaching you imagine a that's like
me learning from Richard Pryor
yeah that's why when I'm around Eddie I
listen and I asked him and I get
inquisitive cuz I'm gonna learn from him
and Arsenio about this and then I get on
stage what did custom mean when he said
Mike well you got him hurry some guy he
got boom the guy the guy said he turning
back the guy out he's not concentrating
his head up and boom the guy hit
something he gets knocked out whoa don't
you hurt the guy and he looks like he's
sleeping this man is dangerous we think
this man is [ __ ] napping right now he's
the most dangerous he I was wounded yeah
he's wounded
and that's the same thing like with a
woman you gotta be careful she wounded
she'll hurt you that's why the old man
you living you learning did you learn
some more I had to learn nothing you
have to learn how to learn you can learn
how to live that's true man that's true
I was excited when you wanted me to do
the show man but I need to come over
hotbox and kick it and kick it I would
love to have you yeah I need to do it
and they need to see Mike Tyson and
Tracy Morgan just kick it that would be
incredible and no one else know where
they need to see it more than just two
black people who may be famous and
celebrities in their eyes but the fact
that we came from the same place we know
things about me that
though I'd even dream that I experienced
you know my father
I'm not going yeah you talk to my father
and I knew right in front of 212 a lot
of times and I'm not going to cross
mother Gaston I haven't been shy which
is well but you don't want to go to
brown Brownsville that's not what you
want to go
you better know somebody in there and
don't be going in there behind oh girl
man
another girl said you have to come
reports they go get come on dirty baby
the dirty world that brother yo come on
man we both went Busan kid do the
stronger you hit every gap in Midtown
you destroyed you get him with the dead
off is the dead among all those guys so
much fun thing with the men CEO in DC
then I know I wrap it all around from
for grain I was up in Tompkins with case
son you know I'm saying so we grew up
people don't realize where we grew up
and we made it out yeah that's the whole
thing that went at the end of us
sometimes when time I love to [ __ ]
Douglas right and I was and I was crying
a nothing Bersani said he said with the
miltenberger with it was one of them one
of old dudes got the probably 100 years
old one day a George Burns one of them I
said you did I said man I failed is that
you didn't feel he is 1:30 me gnarlie
you said we have to go back to France if
you fail will you go back to childhood
scared oh we don't lose we learn when I
learn when I learn you learn every day
lose don't lose right
you got hit hard in the ring I get hard
I got hit hard on the Turnpike
18-wheeler man Tracy begin harder harder
life man and lighting you know I thought
right that the other day I said life got
teeth I said life got teeth in the bite
look the promoter hi it hit there's life
you gotta live it one day at a time I
woke up this morning I lifted my shades
up that said the Sun is up it might be
cloudy but it's up so now you gave me
one more day I'm gonna get on a joint
with Mike Tyson I'm living my life man
I'm praying for those those who are in
dire circumstances and loved ones being
lost I know it's real I know it's real
and the people on the front line that
the nurses and the doctors around and
stuff me and you ain't around we safely
in our homes this people working around
and stuff like it's like a fireman while
we running out the burning house Mike
they run a name that's heavy duty but
that's why the universe made those
people he made those people get four
that he made your mic man we all the
times what we'll be doing yeah I do
stand-up so I'll try to be funny so
people could forget about this stuff for
a minute for a minute just for a minute
that's gonna be our way in heaven we put
ourself in service to others you know
I'll do comedy for me so give me that
knife man laugh at my problems meant
they don't want problems laugh at minds
oh no no I'm one of those guys you know
I know those guys very well Mike man you
told we had a bunch of fun and we love a
bunch of for next season to solutely
then we're gonna stop never never stop
yo would you think about my man
primetime excuse me remember primetime
be either yo Chris Cole Burt you was
talking to him he's super featherweight
champion of the world super
featherweight 130 pound he was chocolate
roll when we was at the show yeah he
wants down he's on he's gonna fight
member the young brother he wants he's
gonna fight
don't pay david you want to fight him
drink tank right and low me ten yeah I
remember talking them even Carano people
you know guys like that need the right
people in that corner abused him to be
very talented he's a great fighter but
nobody heard about him you know he
should be out paint davis and those guys
he needs to be able to affirm that put
them outfit you putting them on your
showing and go to the gym scene and
workout will put him on the map and i'ma
put them you gotta be his manager
absolutely loser talk about fight one
myeloma chanko and Dante Dan oh no no no
right Mike Mike he has easy yet he wants
to go to wrong route
he wants to go to wrong route you got a
stamina right ride in the episode listen
struck me and I'm gonna do it you tell
me to do absolutely cuz he got an
opportunity to take his family but he
won't go sell drugs
absolutely not for real it's gonna be on
a show because me you know the story
then you know the story I know this
waited fight in the world if not the
champion to go fight in the world got
killed in the world I need all of that
we got to write all of that let me say
it to him this is gonna be cuts talking
are you in a dark and a room I'm telling
you I see the vision I'll see the vision
you gonna get an enemy behind this one
well you gonna get any behind this one
imma firin structure that need always we
always see you in the funny I want I
want to show you in this I want to show
you in a different light I want to make
you very uncomfortable that's my job
that's gonna be very difficult I went
back taking a [ __ ] in front of 22,000
people I love it I love it I love it I
love it
I'm give me gonna eat me some lasagna
man I love
you love my case brother thank you